neurologist ted florento joining us now
with a nice pink carnation is that a
live one there sir no it's dead oh all
right
all right wait let me check yeah that is
floral honesty there ted but i'll tell
you what great day today if it just
wasn't for the cloud oh you know what we
want the clouds it's something different
sometimes just a dollop of seattle yes
just that's what we like a dollop of sea
and then it returns to the sun back to
sunshine it's not going to last all day
or all tomorrow either because we're
going to see some changes tomorrow big
look outside though at the las vegas
strip and of course the mountains there
we're getting some snow still the snow
up there on lee canyon canyon if you
went up there this weekend it was a nice
weekend for that 57 degrees our official
high for the day today 38 overnight for
the low again if we didn't have all this
cloud cover we probably could have
reached 60 degrees today but we just had
clouds all day today 75 our record on
this date that was back in 2003
currently outside 50 for summerlin 54
for centennial hills we're at 56 for
downtown and north las vegas 60 even for
sunrise manor 58 for you joining us from
green valley and whitney ranch 54
henderson 53 roads ranch and southern
highlands right now you're at 54 degrees
as well outside of town 56 currently for
indian springs milder for laughlin at 63
and 57 for our good friends out there in
boulder city clouds coming in from the
west but what we're going to see
is another cold front slide through the
region specifically on wednesday
here's your future cast clouds again
today but then tuesday it starts to
clear a little bit we'll watch this
front slide through and as it does wind
ahead of it but stronger wind behind it
along with colder temperatures so
although the skies will clear our
morning temperatures and our daytime
highs are going to be a little on the
chilly side more though on that window
it will peak on wednesday between 30 to
40 miles per hour for the valley and
locally higher for the colorado valley
where we could see a wind advisory
upgraded to a high wind warning still
breezy thursday and some wind left over
on friday there is your nhl all-star
weekend and also your pro ball weekend
breezy again on sunday big temperature
drop too
i love it when kirsten does the
the the sound effects for the 60 on on
tuesday guys okay
then we drop
49 on wednesday that's your high these
are your highs not your high and low so
that's a big temperature drop on
wednesday overnight 45 degrees plenty of
clouds look for light winds tomorrow 60
degrees morning clouds and then clearing
later on today i don't think winds will
be an issue for the first half of the
day but later on in the evening we'll
see those winds pick up a little more
there's that big wind day and the big
temperature drop on wednesday that's
going to be the not so fun day all right
breezy thursday and then temperatures
warm up just in time for the big weekend
for the pro bowl and the nhl all-stars
that's your weather update back to you
ted